jedi are cowards they failed you
where is
it
hello there guys so there has been a new
leaked tv spot for the upcoming obi-wan
kenobi show and it includes new footage
and dialogues let's break it down so the
trailer begins with new dialogue from
raver where she says the jedi are
cowards they failed you for this new
dialogue we have new footage of obi-wan
which looks like he is meditated on the
floor or possibly he is expecting
someone now it looks like he's in some
sort of shipping container or ship but
whatever place he is in it's currently
stationary or underground as we can see
the sunlight shining through and do you
guys think obi-wan is expecting to meet
darth vader in the scene let me know in
the comment section below next up we
have a really cool shot where we see the
shadow of the inquisitor ship which is
flying over tatooine before it makes it
land in which then we have more dialogue
from raver where she says there is no
point in protecting them where is
obi-wan while raver is trying to get the
logos to give up any information
regarding to kenobi or the jedi in
general we also see a shot of uncle owen
here and it looks like he is thinking
carefully because obviously he knows
about kenobi he knows he is a jedi in
exile so will he give up this
information to the inquisitors or will
he keep it a secret and we also do have
some new behind-the-scenes footage which
i'll play for you guys in the background
now it looks like debra chow is getting
good performances out of actors here i
really like the shot we have here of
raver force pushing the civilian into
the wall i like how brutal looking it is
and i hope we get more of this darker
tone from the show as this is one of the
shows set in a dark time period so
hopefully that is really um showcased in
this series but anyway that's pretty
much everything for this video so just
some new dialogue and footage from the
show which i'm sure we'll get more of
leading up to the release of this show
but if you did enjoy this video guys
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching